you want something to drink do we even
eat Jello shots what what do you know
you have to move on Holly Lane
is here Kim any jello shots are like you
can get them when you order them no no
like you have to freeze them you do it
the night before got it I'm definitely
still a lightweight I'll have like two
shots and I'll be wasted and it's so
much fun I'll be dancing on the dance
floor seriously I know you guys don't
believe me
ask Beyonce I danced all night long in
her party
I think I blacked out
but
I woke up to so many text messages and I
will say Chloe look at this what did I
do what did I do and she's like you were
dropping it low and Dan and I was like
no
[Music]
I had no idea